how's it going everybody it's Warren and
we have some really exciting news as
Marvel has officially announced that
Avengers in game will be back in
theaters this weekend with new footage
there was recently a spider-man far from
home press junket and London and during
this junket Kevin Feige the president of
Marvel Studios told many different
sources that Avengers endgame is going
to be hitting the theaters again for a
second round this upcoming weekend and
not only that but it's going to come
with some additional footage that didn't
make it into the official cut in April
Kevin Feige while speaking with Brandon
Davis of comicbook.com talking about the
re-release of Avengers in game said we
are doing that I don't know if it's been
announced and I don't know how much yeah
we're doing it next weekend and then in
an interview with Screen Rant he
commented on what exactly will be seen
Kevin Feige said not an extended cut but
there will be a version going into
theaters with a bit of a marketing push
with a few new things at the end of the
movie if you stay and watch the movie
after the credits there will be a
deleted scene a little tribute and a few
surprises which will be next weekend so
this is official Kevin Feige has
announced that we'll be getting new
footage with the re-release of the movie
and this should definitely help Avengers
end game beat avatar or at least get
insanely close to it especially since
Kevin Feige mentioned they'll be doing a
marketing push for the re-release so
when they rerelease the movie they're
definitely going to mention that there
is going to be new footage new scenes in
the movie we have learned about a few
different deleted scenes that were
supposed to be an Avengers in game since
the movie came out all of which were
very exciting and the tribute is most
likely to Iron Man and the original
Avengers or it could be a tribute to the
fans
however Kevin Feige mentioned that there
will be a few surprises at the end of
the movie in the post-credits and with a
lot of talk about Marvel's phase 4 right
now and San Diego comic-con and Disney's
d23 event coming up it makes you wonder
if any of these surprises are related to
the future of the MCU and phase 4 this
should certainly draw people back into
the theaters to give Avengers in game a
chance at beating avatar Avengers
endgame has already broken a number of
Records but as it stands right now
avatar still holds the all-time global
box office record with 2.7
eight eight billion now Avengers in game
is not too far away it's actually very
close with its total being right now
currently two point seven four three
billion so with Marvel re-releasing
Avengers in game with some deleted
scenes a tribute and some surprises for
us combined with according to Kevin
Feige a heavy marketing push for the
re-release Avengers in game could have a
very good chance at dethroning avatar
and taken the title of all-time global
box office record of two point seven
eight eight billion so be sure to catch
the re-release of Avengers in game in
theatres so you can go catch that
exclusive new footage be sure to LIKE
the video comment below with your
thoughts and favorite superhero or
villain and subscribe to my channel so
you can enter my giveaway and stay up to
date on everything relating to Marvel as
always thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof